(sighs)
(clothes rustling)
(keys jingling)
- Justin?
- Hey... I was just gonna
head out. I had some things to do today.
- Oh, you didn't want to get
like breakfast or something?
- No, I don't think so. I'm not hungry.
I'm just gonna go.
- Okay well let me get
dressed, I'll show you out.
- No! Don't worry about it.
I'll let myself out, it's easier...
Same way I came in right? Just...
It's easier... so.
- Is this about last night?
- No.
Yes, I don't know.
I just, I don't want to
talk about last night.
This was a one time thing.
- I mean it felt pretty real to me.
- What? We had a lot to drink okay?
And...
Mistakes happen when you drink that much.
- Mistake? This was a mistake to you?
- No, that's not what I'm saying.
I'm just, I'm not ready for this.
You know?
I didn't sign up for something so serious.
- But last night you said--
- I'm embarrassed about last night!
(laughs)
My side. I'm gonna sleep like this.
- You're not sleeping on the bed, I--
- I'm bout to, I don't
like, I don't move much--
- You don't like hardwood ground?
- A little bit of room.
- You're my brother to me.
We're brothers.
- I love you like my brother.
- It's not weird, we love each other--
- Yeah
- It's cool, we love each other
- Honestly, we should say this like
every day to each other, we
love each other you know?
- I wanna wake up in the
morning and every day
just text you, "I love you,
hope you have a good day."
- Why don't we do that?
- We should do it.
I mean, I'm a little embarrassed too.
But... I don't--
- [Justin] Look, this is weird.
Like what happened last night? You know?
I don't do that, like
talk about those things.
Like feelings or whatever.
I don't know man, I just like felt
like lonely for a long time
and like didn't really have anyone
like real in my life, you know?
- [Zack] Yeah
- And it was just like...
I don't know if I could've
gotten through this without you, you know?
So... you know... thank you.
- Yeah.
- Like you know we can't go
back to how things were right?
Those days are over, like
everything's changed now.
- Yeah. I know.
I don't wanna go back.
I've never had a friend like that
who I can just talk to.
I really liked last night
and I don't regret it.
I don't regret anything I said.
That's not why you be your
friends with people, you...
(heavy breathing)
Love you like a brother.
(exhales)
- Okay.
So what now?
What, what, how do we do this?
- Wanna go get breakfast?
(snickers)
- Yeah
- Mickey D's or Denny's?
- You know I'm a Mickey D's guy.
- [Zack] We're goin to Denny's.
(laughs)
- [Zack] Yo Cavs Clippers
tonight, who you got?
- [Justin] Man you know Kyrie's my dude.
- [Zack] Wait, Kyrie's hurt.
- [Justin] What!? Since when?
- [Zack] Since the fin--